the taliban is making substantial gains
across afghanistan they have taken the
city of kunduz and its surrounding
province
they say that they have complete control
of the city and local residents have
confirmed to us
that they are inside the police
headquarters inside the governor's
compound inside
intelligence offices the election
commission multiple government buildings
they've even taken the prison
and released prisoners the ministry of
defence says that they are
going to launch a clearing operation to
take the city back but for all intents
and purposes
the city of kunduz has fallen to the
taliban it is a very significant city in
2015 and 2016.
it briefly fell to the taliban it's the
only city that fell to the taliban in
the last 20 years
and the reason that it got back into
government hands is because
u.s special forces were deployed on the
ground but now of course u.s special
forces
are not on the ground and the afghan
government is having to try do it
alone sometimes with the help of u.s
airstrikes but mostly through their own
air force and their own troops
now the taliban is also claiming that
they have taken the province of sarropol
they put out a statement in it they said
that they seized
a huge amount of weapons from both
kunduz and sarri pool and that they are
asking soldiers to surrender or
be killed also in the south the province
of nimrod's foul
and then in joe's jam which is also in
the north
the capital there sherbaghan is
intensely contested
residents there tell us that the taliban
have control of the city but the
government says that they do still have
special forces in the city
and are planning a fight back heavy
fighting continues in
lashkar gar which is in helmand and also
in kandahar
city there's air strikes there's street
to street battles around the outskirts
of the city and in lashkar
right in the center so a terrible time
for civilians there and lashkargar they
have been stuck
in their homes for a week and they are
starting to run out of supplies
we talk to residents there who say they
are absolutely terrified
and that their houses are shaking with
constant bombardments
so the government now being spread very
thin as the taliban take more and more
control of various cities and
territories they're relying on their
special forces and airstrikes to try to
push them out of cities
but being in cities it's very hard to
fight because they are putting the
civilian population
in battle with this type of urban
warfare so the government
in a very difficult situation now that
the taliban have moved into cities
the taliban started this kind of
territorial offensive
right after u.s president biden
announced in april
that all u.s and foreign troops would be
out by september
then the taliban has started this
offensive and taken
initially a lot of rural land and now
they are pushing for the cities
you